hello YouTube just love us in our
friends
this is guns in here and welcome to the
fourth part of my chess reputa against
efore now in this section I am going to
cover what you should do after you open
in place Knight to f3 well here black
has many interesting choices but I am
going to stick with our tried interested
move which is the move f5 known as
Colorado gambit now people who haven't
watched my previous video I strongly
recommend them that go and have a look
to that video where I have covered most
of the response from the white side and
in this lecture I am going to cover only
some of the critical response of the
white and how we are going to deal with
it now before we go and look at those
lines in a depth I like to mention over
here that recently I'm trying Colorado
gambit amongst with my group of friends
and I insist them to come out with a
very good response by white so the games
which I am going to show you in this
lecture are played by people ranging
from 1600 to 2200 plus PD rating and
they have analyzed this lines by their
own and some of them have analyzed
heavily with tangents so you know
you will have a very nice idea how to
handle those positions
okay so first critical move which can be
played by opponent which is night to h4
so Knight to h4 has a simple idea of
giving Queen to h5 check well here I
recommend that you should certainly
capture this for 1 and after Queen check
you just play g6 and after Knight cross
g6 black has to play Knight to f6
attacking the Queen and please note
white Queen has the only space left
which is Queen to h4 if the Queen goes
to the h3 then the very simple from the
black perspective is to play d5 and once
again attacking the Queen
so Queen has to retrieve back to the h4
so in a way white will give one tempo to
the black which cannot be good
so that's why at this position Queen has
to go to the h4 square and after Queen
to h4 black has to play route to g8
attacking the knight and again wide
response is pretty much force white
cannot play Knight to f4 because if you
play Knight to f4 then black will simply
play a route to g4 and white will lose a
piece so that's why Knight cross f8 is
pretty much force at this position and
afterwards black will recapture with the
rook
and now you can see I have highlighted
by the arrows very simple but very
effective plan of the black so what
black wants to do is is to play d5 then
the bishop will go out let's say to f5
then this Queen will go to the d7 and
then black will castle on the Queen side
and then black will go on to the King
side attack of the white and this is
very very effective plan of the black
now if you open in place passive moves
such as Knight to c3 or b3 then you can
pretty much look forward for this plan
so only attacking new white can play at
this point is Bishop to e2 so trying to
disturb black to execute his plan then
this was played by one of my opponent
which was rated 2000 plus against this I
just scared out with my normal PC
development so I played the move d5 and
here he give me this Shack afterwards I
capture that Bishop and after Queen
recaptures I just block the check with
rook to epsilon so route to f7 not only
block the check but also protecting the
critical pawn sitting on at 7 hear my
opponent continue with his fast
development so he castle on the King
side and I played Bishop to f5 so this
Bishop has an idea of either coming to
the g6 or probably in the future
g4 not decided right now
my opponent played b3 now before we look
at b3 if your opponent plays Knight to
c3 as it was played by one of my weaker
opponent then the very simple will be
Knight to d4 and you can see that Knight
is attacking the c2 so that means in the
game my opponent passively retreat the
Queen to the d1 but that allows me to
build up my attack very strongly and in
fact I run the game very very quickly
afterwards but if White Queen doesn't go
back then white will lose an important
pawn and black will have a superior
position so that's why Knight to c3 is
not at all good at this position so in
the game my opponent plays the move b3
and I played Queen to d7 planning to
castle on the Queen side and after
Bishop to b2 I first of all gain a tempo
on the Queen
so I played Bishop to g4 and my opponent
responded with Queen to h4 and then I
castle on the Queen side and here my
opponent attacked the bishop so he
played h3 and I decided to put my bishop
on a very nice diagonals so I played
Bishop to e2 attacking the rook and
after rook to e1 I posted my bishop on a
lovely square which is Bishop to e6
which has a matter of controlling all
the light squares up till the f1
now here finally my opponent decided to
develop his last piece so he played
Knight to c3 but Knight to c3 has a big
drawback because it's simply allow my
knight to jump onto the beautiful square
which is Knight to d4 and you see the
matter of the night to d4 directly
attacking the c2 which white has to
defend so white here played rook a to c1
afterwards I post my rook one the two
open file
so I played rook to G a look at those
routes they are wonderfully placed and
then there is something nasty will
happen very soon right now black is also
threatening Knight to f3 check and
gaining the Queen White has to deal with
that cat so my opponent plays King to h1
afterwards I played a very simple move
which is the movie file protecting my
knight in the center and here probably
my opponent was annoyed by that
centralized night so he want to get rid
of that night so he played Knight to a4
attacking the knight but here I come out
with a very strong move which is rook to
a file so idea of rook to F is not only
attacking the Queen but I want that
Queen to be moved
so the f2 will become loose and after
Queen to f6
I simply snap up the f2 one and now you
can see the matter of that move the
the rooks are eyeing at the juicy g2
square and here probably my opponent was
in time trouble as well because he has a
less than three minutes left in his
clock so he played rook to g1 afterwards
it allows me to focus both the roof by
playing Knight to e2 and seeing that he
cannot save his either of the rook my
opponent grabs some free pawn so my
opponent plays Bishop cross Aoife and I
played a strong move over here I played
Queen 2fi attacking the bishop and the
bishop drawbacks to the h2 square and
now I execute my plan so it's very
simple for me what I did is I simply
capture this rook and after white
recaptured can you spot it the game is
about to over and the critical move is
Rho cross g2 BAM
and at this position my opponent resign
now some of you wondering why he open in
resign the very simple is after route
cross G to black can give this check and
after rook to g1 and Queen to f3 check
the only square left to cover by the
white is paying rook to g2 afterwards
queen cross g2 has a checkmate so that
is one game which highlight how you can
play against nice to h4